サムネイルを見
て言ったら正しいのですが
、アソブと言ったら間違っ
ていますが、この
2つの井戸の違いは、次のような外国語を学ぶときに学ぼうとしていることです。
日本人は、母国語の単語の
ように聞こえる単語の発音と高低アクセントのパターンを簡単に理解して模倣
できます。たとえば、英語を母国語とする人
であれば、簡単に理解して模倣することができます。
この2つの単語の真ん中にあるアクセントは、
どちらも真ん中にアクセントがあり
、
バナナやコンピューター
バナナ
コンピューターなどの英語の単語がたくさんあるため、これらはまったく同じアクセントパターンではありません。
はストレス
アクセント言語ですよく日本語は高低
アクセント言語ですが、ここでのポイント
は、英語を母国
語とする人であれば、おそらくこれらの
2つの単語を言うことができるということです s
そして
、あなたがあまり注意深く聞いていなくても、または本当に集中していない場合でも、それらの真ん中にある種のアクセントがあります。これ
は、ネイティブの英語話者が
今見たようにアクセントを聞くことに慣れているため
です。 発生している場合、発生していない場合でもアクセントが聞こえていると思うことがよくあります。
つまり、ネイティブの
英語を話す人は、低
高低のパターンを選択
することができるため、無意識の
うちに、このような他の単語が私たちのように見えると思い込んでしまうことがよくあります。
低いハイローを聞いて選択するのと同じように発音されたと仮定すると、
このような単語を実行したり、
このような単語を再生
したりして、無意識のうちに
別の3音節またはビート
動詞で終わる単語に出くわしたとします。
おそらく同じアクセントパターンで発音されますが、
この仮定は
非常に似た構造
を持ち、これらの2つの単語が
実際に発音されるのと同じように結合しているにもかかわらず、間違っています。 または
アクセントのないパターンの場合
、これ
はネイティブの英語話者が最初に
理解したり再現したりするのが実際には非常に難しい場合があり
ます。これも、私たちが本当に言いたいアクセントのある単語を言うのに慣れているためです。
hakobuとは言わないでください、
または単にそれらの単語をフラットに言うと
、ギアを回転させるのに十分ではないことがよくあり
ますが、これには大いに役立つトリックがありますので、このアクセントのないパターンで
事前に英語の単語を言ってみてください
以前、英語の単語bananaとcomputerが、bananacomputerの
ようにアクセントなしでこれらを言ってみるのを見ました
。bananacomputermm-うーん、
今度は日本語の単語をもう一度言ってみてください。
と
の違いを聞いて
ください。blで終わる日本の発音動詞を改善するために今日覚えておくことができる簡単なルール
は、通常、このアクセントのないpaにあります。
この3つの単語は、実際には、
この規則の一般的な例外であり、今日見た
ように
、飛ぶ
ように呼び出すなど、他の一般的な動詞です。
今日も見たように持ち運びをしますが、それ
に加え
て、浮くように並べて結び付けることを学ぶこと
はすべてこのアクセントのない家族の一部ですこの
ような他の多くのルール
があり、ピッチをすぐに知ることができます アクセントを付ける
簡単なルール
を1つだけ覚えて、時には数百語までのアクセントパターンを強調します。これらのルールの多くは、
以下にリンクされているパトレオンコースで教えていますが
、最初
に給料や勉強に飛び込みたくない場合は、
始めてください。 今日のこのブートルール
では、で終わる動詞以外
は通常アクセントがない
ことを覚えて
おくのに最適な場所です。また、あなたが yアクセントパターンの異なる単語に、
無意識のうちに拾い上げ
られる単語のアクセントパターンをマッピングしようとしてい
ます。
この知識
だけで、
あなたの知覚に大きな違いが生まれ、日本語を話すことができ
ます。無料でリンクします。 以下のリソース
を使用し
て、日本語の単語の高低アクセントパターンをすばやく簡単に検索できます。
このビデオが
日本語の勉強に役立つことを願っています。
またすぐにみんなと話してください。